this is the bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be with you thank
you for turning into the Deen show I'm
Eddy year host and every week we're here
with a new exciting episode with a new
exciting guest and with all the hocus
pocus mumbo jumbo that's out there
people misrepresenting Islam so-called
experts on Islam you know where to come
to learn about Islam you come to the
Deen show where you get the facts not
fiction from true experts people who
have memorized the verbatim Word of God
the Koran people who live Islam people
who are living this life day to day not
people who are in it for the business
because you know there's big business
and bashing Islam nowadays so don't get
into following the hype that's out there
that's been created to confuse you you
want to get unconfused you've come to
the right place
the Deen show well we've done hundreds
of shows we've done so many shows on so
many different topics and if you just
open your mind you have a sincere heart
and you sit back and you go through some
of our archives if you're not catching
us live on the TV you can go to the Deen
show com and we've covered so many
different hot topics a lot of these
issues a lot of this fiction that people
have put out there and you'll get a
better understanding and you'll see that
you know what it's not is not about
killing innocent men women and children
Islam is not about oppressing
subjugating the women Islam is not about
all this hocus-pocus mumbo jumbo and
that's why people are accepting Islam
submission to establishing a relation
ship with the one who created you the
one guy submitting to him doing the good
that he's told you to do the same way
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
messengers of God they submitted they
called people to have a direct
relationship not submitting or
worshiping the creation but establishing
a direct relationship with the one
create or it's a beautiful thing when
you find out the purpose of life and why
you've been created in our next guest
leading on
to this week's episode our next guest
that's what he did he found figured out
what the purpose of life he came from a
Catholic background he was in the Navy
and he's here today to share his story
on how he came to this to Islam
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
with J Dean when we come back here on
the D show this is the theme the deegeu
this is the things is the thing this is
the thing is the theme this is the theme
back here in the Dean show and we're
here with J Dean assalamu alaikum peace
be with you
y alaikum salam' are talking to lovicott
and peace be back upon you
J Dean Jamal Dean was that always your
name well of course not uh I was brought
up here in the United States and I was
born with the name of James and after
accepting Islam I changed my name to
something that was more beneficial Jamel
which means beautiful in Deen meats
which means the way of life so it's a
beautiful way of life of Islam how did
you have to change your name
it wasn't mandatory but the Prophet may
the peace and blessings be upon him said
if your name is something that is has no
meaning and is undesirable then change
it to something that would be pleasing
to in the sight of God and so this was a
personal choice that I took and Jamel
was very close to the word James so it
was an easy transition but it had
meeting and substance to it so as I said
before Jamel means beautiful and then
Deen means the way of life and I looked
at Islam as the beautiful way of life
that all human beings should follow
trying to worship the Creator now since
you changed your name did you also like
since you accepted Islam like have to
stop being American of course not
most people confuse this and think that
once you become Muslim that you become
this isolationist and that you're
separate from the American Society but
most people do not understand that
Muslims have been here long before most
people in America and so the Muslim
values are here in America they're part
of the Constitution of the United States
and it is something that that document
would not have been possible if it
wasn't for Islam and so actually it is
actually enhanced my being an American
by becoming a Muslim the rules the the
different things that we had to give up
like the bad things in society like
alcohol and premarital sex all of these
things that are very
to a human being when you go ahead and
become my muslim' who you look at these
things and you start to correct these
things and so that's what I did I went
through a process on that and it took me
time it wasn't something that happened
overnight and as I got rid of all of
these things I started to become closer
to my Creator I became a good neighbor I
became a good father he became a good
son and these things were something that
God would like and God would be pleased
with and so this bit made me a better
American I would say tell us a little
bit about your life before Islam
we heard you used to be in the US Navy
my life before Islam I like to say it
was a life without guidance I grew up as
most normal Americans I actually grew up
in a small little farm town with a lot
of cows chickens a you know normal farm
town a very small population very
sheltered the environment wasn't exposed
to many cultures many different
religions many different languages so
very sheltered Society I went through
what most Americans go through they go
through a battle with choosing their own
friends when I was younger and so I
started following people that were
drinking alcohol the whole club scene
things like that and so I went down that
path but I saw something in my mind that
said that this is not the way to live
and so I started to question there has
to be something more to life than this
and so I decided that I needed guidance
I needed morals I needed values and I
thought that I could find this in the
United States Navy and so after
graduating high school in that I decided
to join the US Navy
I traveled around a little bit and I did
get the discipline alhamdulillah all
praise and thanks be to God
but I did not find the guidance in fact
I found more miss guidance than what I
found of guidance after we would get
done being soldiers during the week we
would hang up our bootstraps and then
all of us would head to the bar and so
we would start drinking and we would
start chasing after women
all of the things that normal Americans
do that they do not realize that is very
harmful to their body and to their
relationship with the Creator and so
even on the weekends Annette I was at
the bar so much I decided to start
working at a bar and so I used to be the
one that would check the IDs at the at
the door
kind of like the bouncer of the club and
so that that's kind of where I went into
Islam I met a woman that used to come
into the club she she was underage she
had a fake ID I let her into the club
she fell down the steps one night
because she was so drunk and the club
owner who happened to be Arab at the
time also a Muslim but I did not know
this at the time asked me to get her out
of the club because he was afraid to
lose his liquor license afraid to lose
his club afraid of getting arrested and
so I carried the woman up the stairs put
her into a cab with her and her friend
and I gave her my number she came back
to the club in that and we ended up
starting dating and one day she come to
me and she started crying and she said
someone is going to my mother and father
are going to make me marry someone from
my home country and I don't want to
marry them I said no problem I will go
ahead and marry you she said no problem
there's only one condition
you have to become a Muslim I said is
that it no problem I'll become a Muslim
what is the muscle like I said before I
was very ignorant to the world and
everything in it so I had no clue what a
Muslim was what Islam was I had no clue
what these things were so she said it's
very simple all you have to do is you
have to say there is no god but God and
that Muhammad peace be upon him is his
last and final messenger and then you
are a Muslim so she took me down to the
the local mosque and I took my Shahada
which is the declaration of faith and I
became a Muslim the sad thing is is the
first day that I became a Muslim was the
last day that I was at the mosque and we
still continue to do the drinking and
partying and going out and doing all of
these things that was against the
religion of Islam this way of life so
this is my journey of how I came
to Islam but it didn't stop there as I
started to read more of the Quran as I
started getting understanding of my
relationship with the creator I started
to question things that we were doing
that were going in contrary to what
God's laws were and so we used to get
into a lot of fights about these because
we were kind of at a crossing roads she
was heading out of Islam and I was
heading towards Islam and so at these
crossroads and that we decided to part
ways and I continued my studying I
continued my path on Islam and started
to change some of the defects of
character that I had instilled in myself
from a lot of days of ignorance and
following my base desires and so when I
got rid of all of these things I was
able to focus more on what was important
in life
what each of us is created for to
worship the creator of the heavens and
the earth and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the villages I remember finding out the
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender their self to God is
a Muslim those who surrender submit to
God gods will die see Islam was pure it
was just you just pray to God your
Creator
I am Not Afraid I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand
now you mentioned Muslim Muslim club
owner then you mentioned this woman
who's Muslim and you know all this seems
opposite Islam please elaborate on this
yes when I first came to Islam I liked
to state this and many other people have
said this before me but it's 100% true
if I would have followed the action of
some of the Muslims and would the way
that they were practicing their faith I
would not have chose this way of life
but as I started to research about the
Prophet may the peace and blessings be
upon him of Islam and his message and
what he taught and how he was a
perfection of the morals and characters
of a human being and I followed that
example in the example that he taught to
his followers that right there makes it
a complete way of life God Almighty says
in the Quran he says today I have
perfected your religion for you not for
the Muslims not for for the Arabs but
for all of mankind and so that was what
I was looking for and that was what I
was trying to follow and that's why I
said when I look back on it and I see
that he was an Arab and he was owning a
club which goes against the religion of
Islam because he's selling alcohol he's
promoting an environment where people
are committing illegal sexual
intercourse these sort of things that go
against the teachings of Islam this is
the irony that I saw and so I started
following the practices that are taught
in the Quran and in the Sunna the way of
life that the Prophet may the peace and
blessings be upon him taught to his
followers and so when I did that I saw a
change in myself and I saw a change in
the people that were surrounding me and
this is what why I chose the name of
Jamel Deen the beautiful way of life so
why would anyone want to accept this
with all the negative stereotypes and
stigma that's attached to it but that's
that's the question that is for the ages
better basically we are in need of God's
help and he is in no need of our help
there is a famous hadith that reports
that the Prophet may the peace and
blessings be upon him says that even if
you were the best of creation the best
of human beings the best of the animals
the best of anything that God created
you could not add to God's kingdom and
even if you were the worst of creation
say you were Hitler or say you were
someone that committed the worst
atrocities and mankind throughout the
history of time you could not take away
from God's kingdom so when you put that
in perspective we realized that it is to
our benefit to worship the creator of
the heavens and the earth it is no one's
benefit like if someone comes to this
way of life I get no I get no reward I
expect a reward from the Creator I don't
expect a reward from human beings but it
gives you guidance it gives you a way of
life that gives an equal balance to all
things this is known as the religion of
the middle path you can't go too far to
the left and you can't go too far to the
right you must choose a middle course
and this middle course is the way that
was intended by the prophets all the way
back to Adam to Moses to Noah to Jesus
to the last and final messenger Muhammad
may peace be upon all of the noble
messengers of God and this is what they
tried to teach the people they tried to
teach them away that they could worship
the creator and become noble human
beings and so this is what I wanted to
do and this is why we we do this so much
to spread this message the truth about
how to worship God because it is human
beings that need God God needs nothing
from them now tell us did you take time
to investigate other religions and why
not just follow the religion of your
parents good point
I was I was raised a Roman cat Roman
Catholic but my parents were non
practicing Roman Catholics which is the
case of many Christians in America their
Christian by name but not Christian by
practice and so
I like to call him my Easter Easter
Christians or Christmas Christians they
would go to the church only on Easter
Christmas but the regular services
Sunday and stuff they didn't care too
much about they were too busy working
things like this and so I had concepts
of God I always questioned about the
religion from the very beginning since I
was a little kid and I remember going to
some of the Catholic Church and asking
questions about the creator asking
certain questions that that the nuns and
the priests they used to get upset at
and they used to say you have to believe
you have to blindly believe have blind
faith these sort of things what normally
and Christianity what they tell you so I
wasn't satisfied with that for some
reason God Almighty gave me an
inquisitive mind and I started to wonder
and I started to reflect about my place
my my role in the creation of the
heavens and the earth and so when I
started doing this I had more questions
that could that weren't being answered
in my faith so I started searching
outside of the faith I started looking
into different different isms different
religions I started looking at Buddhism
Confucianism started looking at Marxism
different philosophies a lot of the
Eastern religions mostly because even in
Christianity and Judaism these are
Eastern religions even though they've
been adopted and kind of hijacked by the
West and made Western religions but the
original languages that were they were
revealed in were Eastern languages and
same thing with Islam
the main difference though is in Islam I
wasn't expected to believe in something
I couldn't feel I couldn't touch
I couldn't have tangible right in front
of me not like in judeo-christian
theology where I'm supposed to have
blind faith and to believe in the unseen
without having any evidence in Islam you
are to question these things and in fact
the creator of the heavens and the earth
he encourages this the Quran is revealed
in an inquisitive way it makes you
answer the questions like for example
God Almighty will say in the Quran he
said is a youth that creates the trees
is a you that gives it sustenance
No
course not so what is the thing that
gives that sustenance what is the thing
that gives sustenance to all living
things it's not human beings it's
something greater than us it is God
Almighty and so the answers were there
every single question that I had had had
not answered through judeo-christian
teachings every single one of them I
found a clear concrete answer in Islam
and this is what pushed me towards us
and into this day I still haven't even
lifted the pages I'm still just digging
into the knowledge and I see no end to
the knowledge of learning about the
creator of the heavens and the earth now
Jay Deen Jamal Deen why not just stay
with believing in Jesus that Jesus was
God the Son of God that he paid the
price for your sins what about this the
interesting fact is that Islam is the
only religion that requires as an
article of faith in order to be a good
Muslim to believe in the Prophet Jesus
is one of the mightiest messengers and
that he is in fact the Messiah which the
Messiah means The Anointed One it
actually comes from the Aramaic word
that means masih ha which means - rubber
- annoying and so we accept that that he
is the Messiah the Messiah and we also
accept his miraculous birth he was born
without a father to a mother who was a
virgin we accept this this is one part
of our faith so we are we were actually
a lot better even than in Judaism where
they do not believe that he is the
Messiah so this is a major part of
Islamic teaching and we believe in the
message that was revealed to the Prophet
Jesus may the peace and blessings be
upon him only the message that he taught
to his followers not the message that is
in the books today because a lot of
things have been mixed into the word of
the mighty prophet Jesus I tell I tell
many Christians is I said imagine
imagine if we had 60,000 people
witnesses that used to eat with Jesus
that used to stay with Jesus they used
to sleep around Jesus that used to be
around him imagine if you had 60,000
witnesses that were writing down
the words that were coming from his
mouth what kind of treasure would that
be it would be amazing but unfortunately
today we do not have that but we do have
that with God's final messenger Muhammad
may the peace and blessings be upon all
of the messengers of God and so these
60,000 people were standing around this
prophet getting his words getting his
message and clarifying how to worship
the creator of the heavens and earth and
so this is the beautiful thing about the
religion and so we accept Jesus as one
of the mightiest messengers of God may
Allah be very pleased with his message
and clear him of the atrocities and the
deification that many people do of the
mighty messenger Jesus today tell us
what were some of the challenges that
you faced accepting Islam of course with
anything when you want to bring about
change and that you're going to have
challenges God Almighty says in the last
and final message in the Quran he says I
do not change the condition of a people
until they change what is in themselves
and so there was a lot of bad
characteristics that I had inside of
myself that I had to wash out it was
kind of like taking out the garbage I
had to remove these things from myself
in order to purify myself in order that
I could worship the Creator properly and
in fact one of the main things that
Muslims do before they perform the
prayer is purification so this is the
act of will do which is ablution where
you're going to purify yourself by
washing yourself and your body so you
can be clean before the eyes of Almighty
God and so this purification process is
an ongoing effect of Muslims life and so
the more that you become clean the more
that you get out all of these negative
things the better person you become the
better father you become the better
daughter the better son the better human
being the better neighbor that you
become as a human being in society and
in general now on the regret part there
is not a thing that I regret about
choosing this way of life this way of
life is the one that was traveled by all
of the mighty messengers of God
Adam Noah Jesus Moses all of the mighty
messengers of God and it was very simple
message and it came and it was put the
final seal of all of the prophets with
the last and final messenger muhammad
may allah be pleased with every single
one of them because this is for the
guidance of mankind and this is not
something that human beings should be
afraid of we we have laws we have
constitutions we have things to help the
people and give them guidance imagine if
we had no laws and no guidance it would
be pure anarchy so why can't we as human
beings follow simple commandments given
from the creator of the heavens and the
earth do you not think that he knows
better than we as people human beings
now of course so he's trying to help you
it's not meant to be placed on you as a
burden it's been meant to put there to
protect you from the evils of the human
condition and so when you submit to this
which this submission is your whole body
and your whole self to the will of
Almighty God and this is the definition
of a Muslim Islam itself literally means
one who submits to the creator of
heavens and the earth and one that does
this process is known as a Muslim we
consider all of the mighty messengers of
God all Muslim from Adam all the way to
the final Messenger Muhammad may Allah
be pleased with every single one of them
and reward them for conveying this very
clear message to all of mankind
Jamal Dean J Dean tell us how do you
feel someone can be convinced that Islam
is indeed the true from the creator and
that problem Hamid peace be upon him is
indeed the last and final messenger sent
to mankind now many people ask the same
question of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him and all of the people
question the messengers of Almighty God
with the same questions that you're
asking God Almighty Himself says in the
Quran he said you shall know them by
their acts for one they come to give you
guidance morals and teachings and they
ask nothing in return this is how we
know the messengers of
look at every single one of them every
single Messenger of God live very humble
their very humble and meek servants or
slaves of the Creator they ask nothing
of the people and they tried to give
them morals guidance and support and
they tried to teach them a way of life
the Prophet Jesus may peace be upon him
when his companions the the disciples
when they came to him they they said ya
rabbi rabbi or ya teacher teach us how
to worship the creator of the heavens
and earth and what did Jesus peace be
upon him tell his disciples he said the
Lord's Prayer which every single
Christian knows our Father who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done as it is on earth
as it is in heaven give us this day our
daily bread and forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us as you can see the
mighty messenger Jesus made the peace
and blessings be upon him he kept on
referring to thy kingdom come
he didn't say my kingdom come and he
said give us our daily bread so he was
putting himself among the people each of
the messengers of God never made
themselves above human beings they put
themselves in the same shoes as the
people that they were trying to to
convey this message to same thing came
to the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him the Arabs at the time they
questioned him and said why didn't they
send why didn't God Almighty send us
send us angels to give this message why
is he giving us a somebody this small
little bed doing out in the middle of
the tribal region why why don't he give
us someone with class and nobility
someone that is a better lineage than
this man they questioned him this and
God Almighty Himself answered that
question and said it is I that chooses
who the messengers are going to be not
you and so every single one of these
messengers had the same exact message
from the very beginning all the way
until the final end and so this message
is the one that every single good Muslim
tries to follow what advice do you have
for people who are still living that
life that you left behind my best piece
of advice that I can give
is that the soul of a human being is
prone to evil we like to follow the
things that we are attached to we like
to follow the desires some men for
example desire women some men desire
wealth some men desire children some men
desire luxury some men desire
bling-bling
these things that are part of the earth
but when you die can you take any of
those with you no they all return back
to the earth while you go to a hole
that's six feet in the ground and so you
can't take any of this stuff with you
the only thing you can take with you are
your good deeds and so if you're stuck
in a position like this you have to
understand that if you die in this state
there is no hope for you but if you give
up these things and you try to correct
yourself and try to control your desires
then God will go ahead and give you
support
there's a famous I had these that the
Prophet may the peace and blessings be
upon him says that Allah God Almighty he
said that if my servant takes one step
towards me I take ten steps towards him
if he comes to me walking I come to him
running if he remembers me in a company
I remember him in a company that is
greater than the company he remember
which means the angels and you know the
nobility so if you do these things if
you take your intentions that you want
to find out what the meaning of life is
what my purpose in life is and you want
to come from down here because this only
leads in misery
it may look flashy it may look like it's
it's a complete package that these
people are happy and that you want to
have these things but this is a
deception because if you actually go
into the houses of these people and see
the problems that these people have you
would say I want no part of this I know
I've been to that side and it was
something that I was shocked that that
that is a deception it's a lie and so
these things you you're going to have to
get rid of anyhow
and so my advice to you is to seek out
the truth seek out what is positive seek
out your relationship with the Creator
and he will not fail you he will give
you wealth beyond your dreams if not in
financial wealth and spiritual wealth
where it comes to most would advise
Jamal
Dean do you have for your old boss who's
a Muslim and the young lady that you
knew there was a Muslim and many of the
people out there who have this
background who are Muslim or by name
but not by action my advice to you is
the advice that I would give to any
human being all in the same boat these
material things for example if you own a
store and you're selling alcohol and
you're selling pornography and you're
selling cigarettes and these sort of
things you may gain material wealth but
at what expense you're giving up your
soul why because you're you're selling
things that are harming human beings and
so if you're selling things that are
harming human beings what kind of human
being will you be in the sights of
Almighty God you're promoting someone's
demise and so my advice is to give up
that I know bro I know Muslims that have
owned these stores and they used to make
a lot of money and then we talk to them
we have conversations about these things
and they give up these and they lose
some money they lose some money right
off the bat every single one of them but
after a couple months in that because of
their sacrifice because of their wanting
to change what is inside of themselves
God Almighty
goes ahead and corrects their means in
other ways and so they get blessings
from other areas that they never thought
possible and so my advice is to kick the
devil out and go ahead and start
trusting Almighty God he is the one that
is going to give you sustenance so if
all of mankind was to come and give you
sustenance they
could not give you sustenance except for
if god almighty had written it and if
all of mankind came to take away all of
your substance nobody could take it away
unless it was written by Almighty God
and so they need to turn back to what
make them a Muslim in the first place
and they need to follow the Quran which
is stated that alcohol and pornography
and cigarettes and things that are
harmful to your body are against the
teachings of Islam and they need to go
back to the very basics of Islam and
trust Almighty God and that is the best
advice that I can give to anybody and
for non-muslims this right here these
things right here look at what it's
doing to the society around you look at
what for example like pornography what
it's doing to the society around you you
you have children that are having
horrible crimes being done to them you
have a lot of bad negative things that
are being corrupting the society Islam
comes around and tries to correct the
social problems that are in an
environment and so these things are a
benefit to you so control your desires
and if you give up these things if you
give up these things God Almighty said
he will go ahead and help you out it
will help you out it means that you
never thought possible and so take a
little sacrifice for the for the
meantime and get a better reward for
your sacrifice that's it we're out of
time if people want to have a tour of
the mosque and they want to learn more
about Islam and they're in your area how
can I look you up
I'm very easy to reach you can contact
me at w WK s CA r e s m n o RG or I do
the Dawa program for the Minnesota with
a Minnesota Dawa Institute in Masjid
Dawa located in Saint Paul Minnesota you
can find them on the web also if you
want to come to Minneapolis I'm more
than willing to take you on a tour of
any of our mosques and show the
different teachings that we are teaching
this
students we're trying to teach them how
to become good leaders to become good
husbands to become good wives to become
good children and to work on getting
education and both Islam and also in
non-muslim education so they can become
prominent citizens in the societies that
they are in and this is part of Islam
we're to be good neighbors were to be
good people and we're supposed to uphold
what is right and to forbid what is
wrong and so we need to step up to the
plate to help out all of our fellow man
inshallah God willing
thank you very much may God Almighty the
Creator Allah reward you said I would
like peace be with you
Salaam alaikum what argument to
elaborate okay